in 2015 he played a real person in a
movie for the first time so you were
yeah you were Steve uh Wozniak so what
so what was that like meeting him it was
cool yeah I got to hang out with Steve
Wozniak for uh those I didn't he he
essentially invented computers um he
invented uh like the microchips that
were able to produce like uh personal
computers as we know it so without Steve
Wozniak like computers would be the size
of you know like this room essentially
and he's the guy who made them something
a person could own on their own and not
only that he's the person who conceived
the idea that every person might want to
have their own computer one day yeah
um is that did that did was that
intimidating to play him it was until I
I and then you meet him and he's such a
funny silly guy and I I actually went to
the magic castle with him and I don't
know if anyone's been in the Magic
Castle but it's wild and and and The
Magicians love him the magician you know
if you're a magician Steve wozniak's a
big deal like like that's a real
cross-section of Interest I would say
okay
um because magicians spend a lot of time
alone
so and it's funny because you're like
what's he gonna be like and and he's a
genius um and a little eccentric in some
way so at the end of the night what's
funny is we're walking him out him and
his lovely wife and we're going to the
parking lot of the Magic Castle and I go
to the valet
and I'm like uh it's dark out you know
and I Valley I hand them the ticket and
I'm like did you guys drive here and
they're like oh we actually took Segways
here
um and I'm like oh
Segways that's funny and I was like I
bet you guys were pretty early on the
Segway bandwagon I would imagine and
he's like what's actually amazing is if
we have the first two Segways ever like
serial numbers one and two and he's like
do you want to see them and I'm like
obviously and so he walks me and my wife
down to like a dark corner of the
parking lot we're just leaned up against
like a shed are two Segways and him and
his wife get on the Segways and and and
he's like what's funny about these
though is because they're the first
generation they don't have lights yet so
I was like how are you gonna get home
we're on Hollywood Bowl like what are
you gonna do and he's like we're staying
a few blocks away and they literally
pulled two flashlights out of his pocket
and I'm like you're just gonna segue
home holding one flashlight with one
head and the segue with the other and
he's like yeah we do this all the time
and him and his wife just hopped on the
Segways and zipped off down the road
like literally holding and if you drove
past them you'd be like oh there's two
crazy people but in reality yeah
[Laughter]
gosh that's a random thing it's very
random yeah so they'd work far I take it
then because yeah that had they were
staying at the W when we were at the
magic cat that's about 20 minutes I
don't know how fast Segways go that's
how fast I don't think
oh okay looking to the Future years um
you've been open about not wanting kids
so is this still a thing okay
uh why why like you just never saw
yourself as now you just like your time
it doesn't seem that fun
yeah it really does not it doesn't seem
fun and most of my friends who are
parents God bless them spend a lot of
their time talking about how much they
don't like having kids
and what me and my wife spend a lot of
time talking about is how much fun stuff
we can do because we don't have kids I
think that that's actually pretty rad
though because I I never I never wanted
kids like whenever before I met my ex
and then he had kids and I was like oh
this is kind of cool yeah I was like and
I got to kind of experience yeah that
seems like a good version of it so then
I ended up having kids because they're
so I would I wouldn't say it's like the
most fun job because it's like
overwhelming but it's a beautiful thing
and it's like nothing cooler for me but
I will say though I think it's important
because people always used to pressure
me about it yeah about marriage and
about having kids and like it's like not
everybody that's not everybody's dream
is to do that and a lot of people I
think it's important you say that yeah a
lot of people have kids and they don't
even think about it oh my God all those
people that have accessories yeah yeah
or they just think that's the next thing
you do in life and then they look back
and they were like I didn't have to have
kids no my yeah my friend was like
that's a person as a kid as an accessory
I'm like that's not that's a lot of
therapy in the waiting um but anyway but
you don't need kid there's so many kids
I know and that's the thing too yeah
good looks at all the kids out there and
things I wish there were more kids
I guess anybody that wants kids yeah not
me I think that's cool and your wife is
the same way right she does not want
kids no we get a lot of I don't know I
know people describe having kids yeah as
like brief glimmering moments of beauty
amongst a sea of pain it kind of whereas
not having kids is just it's just lovely
all the time there's there's none of
that it's just great all day I'm never
like I wish I had kids and I'm missing
something by not having them I'm more
I'm doing stuff all the time where I
look over in my life and she looks at me
and we're like if we had kids we
couldn't do this yeah this wouldn't even
remotely be on the table no that's why
any of this stuff people with kids
that's what we call me times oh you have
to carve it out all the time is me why
would I who why would it
I think that's really awesome and I
think it's so cool to not pressure
people and enjoy no idea there should be
more voices
yeah you don't need to have kids also
like won't the world not be here in 30
years
oh my God why do you love my children
this
is
for children probably more than they do
it seems
it's like a grandparent
[Music]
s
[Applause]
[Music]